rustle open your favorite beverage and
take a seat in your giant baseball glove
leather chair because loot is back when
you're hungry as a horse make sure to
use this hungry as a horse measuring
tool so you'll be sure to get enough
food if you're still hungry but are too
lazy to write down a shopping list you
can use this voice command grocery list
maker that will also print it out
just remember to add these edible bugs
and be sure these anatomical chocolates
from visual Anatomy are on there as well
you can get individual body parts or
order an assortment of them in a box set
that includes kidneys brains vertebrae
and even a colon if you're experiencing
problems with any upset body parts you
can decorate your IV bag with these IV
decals from little love medical and
customize your pack so you can get some
leopard print as well as these cool
comic book themed ones never be bored
again after strapping on this Simon Says
belt buckle and playing with yourself or
let your cat play with this
solar-powered cat toy that requires no
batteries only the power of the Sun or
cat a pulp then with these combat
catapults where you build your own
catapult and battle your friends by
throwing a camera at them okay you'll
need a nap after catapulting cameras but
be sure to first warm your PJs up in
this PJ warming bag and then fall asleep
in comfort and privacy with your hoodie
travel pillow wake up and tell yourself
you're awesome with this chalk mug that
you can ride on but even with that in
your possession the neighbors probably
still have better stuff doormat because
they own this awesome bulletproof couch
bunker there's a fire rated gun safe
hidden under bulletproof cushions that
can be removed and used as shields from
bullets so yeah
continue to be awesome and use this
human slingshot go fling yourself or
make your own zipline with this kit
because you've always wanted to zip
yourself let your kids use the zipline
while you read how to not kill your baby
and while in the yard put out these
adorable skeleton garden gnomes
that are sure to scare away all of the
squirrels if that doesn't work maybe
hanging this wall-mounted squirrel head
will do the trick
luckily it will match your squirrel
print throw blanket for Less
death-defying activities get some of
these tiny paper dinosaur fossils that
you can build yourself or try to buy
things with all of the money origami
you'll make with this instructional book
that you keep safe organized and genetic
and your DNA shaped bookshelf which will
go nicely with these cool drink coasters
made from recycled rubber fire hose
recycled firefighter calm up cycles old
firefighter parts into everyday items
like iPad sleeves pet collars and duffel
bags always stay in touch with this fire
fueled battery charger for your phone
and other electronics called flame stoer
check out the Kickstarter page for more
info but first remember commas save
lives
you're welcome grandma and as always
thanks for watching
[Music]
I'll get you
you
you